is from mashable it says earlier this
week a twitter user shared pictures of
what she thought looked like cameras
disguised as fire sprinklers scattered
throughout her airbnb in philadelphia
this prompted other users to begin
sharing their air and b
airbnb horror stories on twitter one
investigation conducted by the
philadelphia police concluded that there
were no hidden cameras in the airbnb the
social media damage had already been
done and so that's why on twitter there
were trending for a while airbnb people
were sharing their horror stories of
being at airbnbs um
and uh some of the tweets someone says
lol airbnb hosts are like i need you to
take your shoes off in the house take
the garbage out turn the music down if
you want to live under this roof you got
to follow my rules it's like you're
living at your parents house at 19 as a
service someone else says we just
abandoned an airbnb in new york city
claimed to have ac in a double bed also
had lovely stains on the sheets and
couch
and there was a
apparently a turd that was i don't know
if this was this
amber heard's house that he was staying
at
but there was there was fecal matter in
the house apparently a lot of other
horror stories like this i'm just
reading this to get to the point that i
want to make
which is um
why are you all staying at airbnbs there
are limited circumstances where i can
understand it like if you're going away
on vacation you want to find a home like
a lakefront home or something and maybe
you use airbnb for that if you need a
long-term rental you're staying
somewhere for three months maybe use
airbnb for that but people use airbnb
when they're just visiting town for a
few days they use it when they're
traveling
and that's what i don't get
you want to go stay in somebody's house
you want to stay in someone else's house
and pay for it staying in other people's
houses that's the worst thing
i don't like staying in my own families
if i'm visiting family i prefer to stay
in a hotel then stay in their house
because it's uncomfortable it's awkward
you know nothing is set up the way that
you would set it up uh you're in someone
else's house it's their rules it's their
everything
they never have their kitchen set up the
right way every time i'm in somebody
else's kitchen i'm just thinking to
myself why would you put the forks and
knives here why would you put the cups
there not over there it doesn't make any
sense the way things are laid out
makes no sense to me
especially when you consider there's a
whole industry
that had previously been set up for the
purposes of providing accommodations to
travelers it's called the hotel industry
and hotels are great
i love hotels i'm a hotel enthusiast
some hotels aren't good but you know if
they're not going to be good based on
the brand based on the price so you know
what you're getting into ahead of time
and the hotels are specifically designed
for the purpose of staying in for a few
days when you're on the road you know
everything's going to be
if you can't find it you can call down
and there's there's a whole staff that's
there and their whole job is to just
wait on you hand and foot
there's a bar that you you someone will
come and ch and make your bed every
morning if you want they'll bring fresh
towels it's fantastic
the only reason it's saying airbnb is
that it's cheaper but it's actually not
cheaper anymore a lot of times it's more
expensive
[Music]
so stay in a hotel this message brought
to you by the hotel industry actually
i'm doing it for free because i'm that's
how generous i am
if you want to join my exclusive fan
base or a cult as really that's what it
is we're joy we're forming a cult then
all you got to do is click the subscribe
button and ring the bell below uh this
video to stay up to date with all my
content and if you want even more you
can watch or listen to my show at
thedailywire.com spotify or apple
podcast looking forward to welcoming you
to the sweet baby gang